despite recent reports a spokesperson
for prince harry and meghan markle tells
et they will not be visiting london this
week to attend an event honoring the
late princess diana so for now we
shouldn't hold our breath for a royal
reunion
the relationship between harry and
william is still very much one of
distance and i don't just mean physical
across the atlantic but they just aren't
talking that much you know that's
exactly how sources close
to william have put it the event which
will be hosted by prince william was
originally scheduled to take place at
the same time as the unveiling of diana
statue at kensington palace this past
july which harry did attend
but due to covet 19 limitations it had
to be postponed and drastically scaled
back now the spokesperson confirms there
are no plans for harry and meghan to be
in the uk for the private donor event
and while the duke and duchess of sussex
won't be in attendance there will be
several vips including diana's longtime
friend sir elton john as well as members
of the spencer family and donors who
helped fund the statue back in july
harry and william unveiled their mother
statue together in the sunken garden at
kensington palace we did see the
brothers come together for the important
moments both sides are able to put
everything to one side when it comes to
focusing on the bigger more important
moments most importantly to the brothers
remembering and honoring the life and
legacy of their mother
but unfortunately that hasn't led to
sort of any bigger movements these are
still two brothers that aren't in
regular communication or in much
communication
at all and i think that whilst they
remain on these very different paths
we're not going to see
much change there and while harry and
megan haven't been back to the uk
together in a while the couple did
travel to new york city last month for a
series of events here they are alongside
new york city mayor bill de blasio
during a visit to one world trade center
they also made an appearance at global
citizen live to promote covid19 vaccine
equality and while in this country and
many others you can go almost anywhere
and get vaccinated billions of people
around the world cannot of course
harry's relationship with his family
remains strained after he officially
stepped down as senior member of the
royal family earlier this year there is
still some feelings of anger there over
the way in which the couple
sort of carried out their departure from
their royal lives and you know i think
for william that's something that he
clearly hasn't been able to come to
terms with yet
and i think harry as he continues to
thrive in his new life has absolutely no
regrets about the way in which he did it
or the decisions that he made and that
does
create this very big gap between the two
sides
[Music]